استمعوا الى هذا الإعلان التاريخي
لقد نجحنا في تجربتنا للقنبلة الهيدروجيني
ولقد حققت النجاح المطلوب لكي يكون سلاح رادع
هل سمعتم ما قالته هذه المذيعة
التي تختص بنشر أمجاد كيم جونغ؟
هكذا أعلنت مذيعة كوريا الشمالية
عن نجاح القنبلة الهيدروجينية التي تم إطلاقها!!!
فبضغطة زر سوف يعود العالم
مئات السنوات إلى الوراء!
هل يستطيع كيم جونغ تنفيذ هذه الخطوة؟
نعم فزعيم كوريا الشمالية لا يمزح!
فقد هدد الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
بمسحها من على وجه الأرض!
لقد أجبر  أمريكا على التفاوض
بعد أن كانت تمضي قدما في الحل العسكري؟
الزعيم الكوري يهدد العالم بأسره هذه المرة،
فهل تستفزه بعض الدول فيمضي في قراراه؟
ثم ما الذي يستطيع كيم جونغ فعله لعالم مترامي الأطراف
من الشرق إلى الغرب ومن الشمال إلى الجنوب؟
لن يستخدم كيم جونغ سوى قنبلة واحدة
فما هي هذه القنبلة التي تهدد العالم أجمع؟...
في العام ٢٠١٧
أجرت كوريا الشمالية تفجيرا كبيرا تحت الأرض،
ساعات قليلة بعد ذلك،
وأعلنت أنه تفجير ناجح لقنبلة هيدروجينية.
انزعجت الكثير من الدول إثر ذلك التفجير
خصوصا الدول المجاورة،
لكن الدولة الأكثر انزعاجا
كانت الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية !!
لماذا يا ترى؟...
أدركت واشنطن من خلال البيان الكوري الرسمي
الذى تمت إذاعته أن التجربة الهيدروجينية الكورية
ليست هي الخطر الرئيسي الذى يمكن أن يهددها،
وإنما هناك سلاح آخر أشد خطورة وفتكا
لوحت به كوريا في وجه الولايات المتحدة
ما أجبر واشنطن على إعطاء الأولوية
للحل السياسي التفاوضي بدلا من الحل العسكري
كما كانت تلوح من قبل...
فما هو هذا السلاح الذي أرعب أمريكا
وأرغمها على التفاوض عوضا عن الحرب؟...
إنها (القنبلة الكهرومغناطيسية)،
هي قنبلة إلكترونية تقوم بتعطيل الأجهزة الإلكترونية
من خلال النبضة المغناطيسية الكهربائية الكبرى
التي يمكنها التداخل مع الأجهزة الكهربائية /
والإلكترونية ونظم تشغيلهم لإلحاق أضرار فيهم وإصابتهم بالتلف....
فيمكن لهذه القنبلة أن تعيد مدينة بأكملها
مئات السنوات إلى الوراء،
حيث تقضي على الكهرباء والأجهزة الإلكترونية،
ما يعني العودة إلى السيف والقلم والرقعة والحصان،،،
كل ذلك بضغطة زر واحدة من كيم جونغ
فماذا لو ضغط على العديد من الأزرار المشابهة؟
.. يا لهذا الجنون
فقد أصبح مصير العالم بين يدي زعيم مجنون
لماذا يخاف الأمريكان تحديدا من هذا الهجوم؟..
بالنسبة لكيم جونغ فإن أمريكا هي عدوه الأول
، إذ لو قرر الهجوم بهذه القنبلة
فلن تكون إلا من نصيب أمريكا،
وستتسبب هذه القنبلة، بغلق شبكة الكهرباء الأمريكية
لفترة غير محددة،
مما سيؤدى إلى حالات وفاة خلال عام واحد،
تصل إلى 90% من جميع الأمريكيين".
وبينما كانت أمريكا تخاف أن يتجه كيم جونغ
إلى هجوم نووي تقليدي، يدمر أكبر المدن الأمريكية،
فإن الزعيم الكوري أصبح يفضل النبضة المغناطيسية
حيث لن يضطر لإلقائها على المدينة التي يريد تدميرها
كالقنابل النووية،
بل يكفي أن يفجر قنبلته المغناطيسية
على ارتفاع مئات الأميال ليوقف الطاقة الكهربائية بالكامل
في أمريكا، ويستمتع بمشاهدة الأمريكان
يتجرعون مرارة الموت!!!
قالت صحيفة "وول ستريت جورنال" الأمريكية
إنه في أسوأ السيناريوهات،
يمكن أن يستمر انقطاع الطاقة لشهور
ما سيؤدي بشكل غير مباشر إلى حتف العديد من الناس،
نظراً لأن المستشفيات ستكون بدون طاقة
وخدمات الطوارئ لن تعمل بشكل طبيعي
كما يمكن أن يعاني الناس من نقص المياه والطعام.
مع هذا التهديد من زعيم كوريا الشمالية،
أصبح المسؤولون الأمريكيون يركزون،
على كيفية تقليص الضرر المحتمل بقدر الإمكان،
عن طريق تعزيز الدفاعات الصاروخية
لتدمير القنبلة الكورية الشمالية
قبل أن تتسبب في أي ضرر.
ويقترح الخبراء، أن تشيد الولايات المتحدة
شبكة كهرباء يمكنها تحمل الذبذبات المفاجئة،
مثل ما تم فعله من قبل لحمايتها من الصواعق الطبيعية،
كما يمكن بناء أنظمة احتياطية
يمكنها العمل في حال تعطلت الرئيسية.
فكيف للولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
أن تتجنب غضب كيم جونغ؟
وكيف لها أن ترد هجوما كهذا؟
وهل تعود أمريكا للحل العسكري في كوريا الشمالية
للتخلص من مخاوفها؟
وماذا عن بقية دول العالم هل ستنتظر أن يقرر كيم جونغ مصيرها؟
...